you are worse than a fool michelle said
getting to her feet the pistol in her
hand
you have no care for your species for
thousands of years men dreamed of packs
with
demons only now were such things
possible
and what would you be paid with what
would your price be for aiding this
thing to free itself
and grow that
is william gibson's framing for an ai
becoming a
super intelligence that helping them
become that is like making a pact
with a demon and i love it but i want to
explain why neromancer
the arthur c clarke hugo nebula
award-winning
genre defining book uh is not my
favorite example
of his writing and that if you want to
get into his work i would suggest
starting with
burning chrome or why i didn't
necessarily enjoy this as much as i
hoped as a fan
of the cyberpunk genre yes hello momo
also this was not meant to be my first
video of the year but paramount is
blocking
uh my big avatar video on the main
channel so you know
burn them to the ground uh but i can do
this
so let's talk about it neuromancer is
set in a world where ai are not allowed
to become
super intelligences for fear of them
taking over
i can understand that but to get around
that
someone creates kind of two halves to an
artificial intelligence
that are destined to join together or
they really want to and when they do
they will fuse and become that hyper
super intelligence
way beyond our understanding and this
book is about
case a hacker who is blackmailed into
helping that ai
do it a hook that really got me from the
start and framing that really excited me
now let no fact but cyberpunk is
basically my favorite genre later on
2049
is my favorite film of all time and i
love that it's a film
so based in its thematic questions and
this book
helped codify the tropes that we
identify with the genre think
neon lights uh the influence of japanese
culture
the contrast and juxtaposition of high
technology and
low life with an emphasis on the
problems of large corporations
this is the quintessential cyberpunk
book you can see the matrix in it with
a digital world that like computer code
can be bent or broken
you can bend or break or manipulate the
digital world as well through a kind of
hacking or
you can see ghost in the shell with its
transhumanist themes where the line
between the
computer and the brain kind of get a bit
blurred till they're almost one of the
same in some cases
but i have complicated feelings about
neuromancer
on the one hand i love so much of what
it does with its world and
themes that it's fast paced and it's got
high stakes the whole way through it
dragged me from the beginning
to the end and gibson's way of
visualizing the digital world is
creative and compelling like if you
uh hack through something then you
create a door inside a wall
or you use a battering ram which
represents a hacking program or a key
and you smash through it
you feel claustrophobic when he's
describing these coffins and yes that's
the word that he uses to describe these
tiny little sleeping apartments that
poor people uh
sleep in and it kind of makes you feel
hatred for the
opulence of lady three jane when you
realize just how much
space she has i could really visualize
winter mute which by the way is a
fantastic name for an ai
uh with every word that gibson gave him
on the page wintermute is only part of
another
a shall we say potential entity i
let us say and merely one aspect of that
entity's brain it's
rather like dealing from your point of
view with a man whose lobes have been
severed
let's say you're dealing with a small
part of the man's left brain
difficult to say if you're dealing with
a man at all in a case like that
it's just so full of character but
despite this great setup i found that
the actual way that william gibson
wrote all of this didn't communicate a
lot of it very clearly
i mean just listen to this passage here
he withdrew the line through the library
ice
it whipped back into his program
automatically triggering a full system
reversal
the scent slash netgate snapped past him
as he backed out
sub programs whirling into the core of
the icebreaker as he passed the gates
where they had been stationed
out brew he said
that's the sort of writing that you get
and it doesn't stop by the way
that's how it is the entire way through
the book or later
on take this the scent net ice had
accepted his entry as a routine transfer
from the consortium's los angeles
complex
he was inside behind him viral sub
programs peeled off
meshing with the gates code fabric ready
to detect any real los
angeles data when it revived there is a
lot
and i mean a lot of techno babble in
this book
uh jargon that's explaining how hackers
do
things how they solve problems without
the reader necessarily
understanding quite why sometimes
problems can just be
solved and you go oh how how did they do
that because he doesn't explain
any of these terms in the book
at all pretty much and even if you have
a kind of
vague understanding of what they might
mean it's still hard to navigate exactly
what he's saying at a lot of points
sometimes it's hard to know quite what
is happening you might have to read
passages multiple times and
those passages that i read before i only
kind of understood them because
knit runner a card game that i really
like is based
on this book so it uses terms like ice
breaker
subroutine so i kind of had a vague
understanding of what they might mean
but not everyone has played this card
game
this is fine the techno babble if it's
every so often but it's
constant in this book it's pretty
unrelenting and unforgiving
and the end result is that i think i
might have missed some character or plot
beats because i was
snagging my brain was snagging on trying
to figure out these other things that i
was never really meant to understand
and as such i dismissed some exposition
that i was meant to remember
as technobabble and that's not great now
the good side of technobabble is that
it's incredibly immersive with this book
if anything it leaves you with a
distinct impression of what this world
is like i
left neuromancer with a real feel and
vibe for william gibson's world that he
has created
one that i wanted to spend more time in
and that's great but the pros doesn't
flow as well
as it could have there's also a lot of
switching between
time and place different times different
places different perspectives
and you can sort of do it like that on a
flip of a
dime and i spoke with my friend benji
from the tail foundry who also really
enjoyed this book and he agreed that we
both got a little bit lost around the 75
percent mark
in terms of knowing why people are where
they
are and what they're doing there
there's that all comes back to that
technobowl stuff is that you kind of
miss
important points of exposition because
you dismiss it along with
so much of the other information you're
trying to process but gibson does manage
to bring this all together at the end
and you do kind of understand how it all
ends up and why the characters are fine
i mean but this is a trait of older
sci-fi as it is the
characters of case molly armitage i
didn't get quite a
great sense of who they were but i did
really good good scenes of wintermute
who is a major character in the book but
i mean
don't listen to me what do i know this
book won the arthur c clarke
hugo and nebula awards all on its own so
clearly it was doing something
incredible
uh at the time and maybe i just didn't
get it maybe i'm
i'm just not smart enough but i still
really did enjoy neuromancer and i
didn't want to leave this iconic world
that gibson created however
if you want to get into the cyberpunk
genre if you want to read his work
then i'm not going to suggest
neuromancer i'm going to suggest
burning chrome this is a series of uh
short stories by william gibson set in
the same world
but i feel that it has all the strengths
of
neuromancer and not nearly as many of
the flaws the techno babble in this is
a lot lighter it's a lot more accessible
you know exactly what the piece of
technology that they're dealing with in
any given story
does and why it's important uh and it's
not obscured by a whole lot of language
the characters i also felt i could
really get a sense of but i also think
that the short story medium
really works for gibson it allows him to
take a really close look at someone's
life and how it's impacted by a
particular piece of technology
that he wants to play with it's
philosophical it's thematic
it's deep it's complex the characters
felt real so yeah if you want to get
into gibson and cyberpunk in general
then do get burning chrome
and burning chrome by the way is a
fantastic short story in here
it's got sort of the same heist feel as
neromancer because they're both high
stories but this one
in my opinion was better i
i really liked it anyways that's all
from me i hope you guys have um
had a good kind of start to 2021 i'm
sorry that i haven't got a channel
um a video out on my main channel yet
it's paramount the
company is being a deck uh it's two and
a half hours long
i've been working on it for months and
um it will be out when i've resolved
those issues i've also got on writing on
world building stuff coming
and more channels one of my big aims for
this year is is more uh
videos on the second channel so see you
guys in the future